neuroscientists have always believed
brain implants to be the panacea for all
debilitating injuries today we explore
this obscure medical research field
known as bmi or brain machine interface
scientists have finally been given the
green light to begin human trials to
prove their concept the company that has
received the approval is called syncron
but obviously as a fanboy i couldn't
very well talk about this topic without
discussing elon's neuralink as well so
in this video i'll take a look at both
but before i get on with that let's
first understand what bmi actually is
what is bmi bmi is essentially a direct
communication pathway between the
brain's electrical activity and an
external device this pathway is achieved
by using a brain computer interface or
bci bci is any device that translates
neural information into commands capable
of controlling external software or
hardware such as a communicator or
robotic arm tilted it towards yourself
and sip and coffee from a straw
and that was the first time in nearly 15
years consider bcis as a bridge through
which individuals with motor or sensory
impairments can communicate with the
rest of the world using different types
of devices this technology is often used
as an assisted living device for
paralyzed people so bcis have been
around for decades having first been
researched by jacques vidal at the
university of california los angeles or
ucla in the early 70s they are primarily
of two types non-invasive and invasive
most bcis since their development have
been of the non-invasive type these are
the caps you see being put on people's
heads with electrodes sticking out they
have limitations since our skull is in
the way which blocks the signal's
efficiency the other is the invasive
type which is a lot more efficient but
it literally requires a chip being
inserted inside the brain by cutting out
a portion of the skull scientists have
experimented with this type of bci
mostly on animals however some limited
human experimentation has been done the
first devices implanted in humans
appeared in the mid-1990s this was the
utah array
it's composed of a hundred little micro
needles the utah array has been the
current industry standard for bci
technology since then it is a small
square computer chip with spikes coming
out of it electric array consists of 100
micro electrodes little micro needles
that are about a millimeter and a half
long that project out from a silicon
substrate the needles are extremely
sharp
and so this device can be implanted into
the cerebral cortex or into the
peripheral nervous system
the spikes go into the brain after
cutting out a chunk of the skull and
deliver electrical signals from the
brain to a computer box attached to the
head the computer box then sends the
signals to the intended device even
though it is the standard of the bci
world the utar array is still very
reliant on 90s technology and since its
success there has been very little
movement in the bci industry until a
couple of years ago elon's neuralink so
earlier i mentioned all our favorite
tech billionaire elon in 2016 he founded
neuralink to develop a device that can
be implanted into a human brain and
communicate with a computer to translate
a person's thoughts into action it was
revealed that the company's goal would
be to treat brain related disorders and
try to cure them a pretty ambitious goal
if you ask me but no scientific
discovery would exist if there were no
ambitious people like him so since 2016
neurolink has been developing a fully
implantable wireless high channel count
bci implant that will enable people with
paralysis to directly use their neural
activity to operate computers and mobile
devices despite significant progress it
is not neuralink that has received
approval for human trials but a
competitor company called syncron
instead in all likelihood this is
because of how neuralink works so how
does it work anyway well the device is
implanted by removing some skull
material then electrode wires are
inserted into the outer cortex layer
using a robotic sewing machine the
electrode wires go in a couple of
millimeters enabling the robot to place
the electrode directly onto the neuron
that they want to read this results in
massive amounts of signal coming out of
the brain and clearer communication with
the linked external device the electrode
is so small that the skin can be folded
back and sewn up afterwards even though
this is a super invasive procedure you
can rest assured that you will not be
walking around with any major visible
signs of the implant it may leave a bit
of scarring but soon it'll not be
visible when the hair grows back with
elon involved you know he's going to
push boundaries somehow with neuralink
he intends to create an unprecedented
kind of robotic brain surgery talk about
unprecedented no one has ever had a
robotic sewing machine stitch into a
human brain before but that's what
neuralink will attempt to do recently he
also said that the intention is to have
the entire procedure performed by a
robot
so this is our surgical robot and we
actually ultimately want this robot to
do
uh essentially the entire surgery
so
in everything from from
incision
uh
removing the the skull inserting
electrodes placing the device um and
then um closing things up and having you
ready to leave
there are various advantages to this
robotic surgery the procedure can be
done in less than an hour and without
general anesthesia also the promise
recovery time is fast because patients
don't have to be admitted for it you can
literally walk into the surgery and an
hour later come out as a cyborg with the
ability to control devices with your
thoughts did anyone else get flashes of
the terminator and skynet after hearing
this because i certainly did anyways
looking at what the intention is one
can't help but root for the success of
neuralink although it has not yet
received human trial confirmation
because of this invasive procedure the
good news is that they have already
received its fda breakthrough device
designation the fda is the united states
food and drug administration it is the
agency responsible for protecting public
health by ensuring the safety efficacy
and security of drugs and biological
products among other things the fda's
breakthrough device designation is
granted to novel medical devices that
have the potential to provide effective
treatment to life-threatening or
irreversibly debilitating diseases this
is a major step forward and a great
milestone for neurolink as it means that
the fda recognizes the life-changing
potential of its device but because of
the complexity of its surgical procedure
it is not surprising that neuralink may
need to wait a little longer for human
trials but how is the synchron device
different and why have they received the
green light for human trials over
neuralink synchron stentrode neuralink
is not the only startup exploring bcis
synchron neurolink's biggest competitor
made headway and got fda approval for
limited human trials on six patients in
july of 2021. before that they had
already tested the device on two
patients in australia as well also
founded in 2016 their device the
stentrode is an endovascular brain
implant it is designed to enable
patients to wirelessly control digital
devices through thought and improve
functional independence much like
neuralink's device however when it comes
to getting the implant inside the human
body their procedure is significantly
less invasive than that of neuralink the
stentrode is designed to be implanted
through the patient's vein until it
reaches the brain what we're doing
differently is using the blood vessels
as the natural highway into the brain
and lacing the inside of the blood
vessels with electrodes or sensors that
can record activity from the brain
instead of drilling through the skull
the stentrode is inserted through a
catheter into the patient's jugular vein
the catheter runs all the way up into a
blood vessel that is nestled within the
motor cortex of the brain when the
catheter is pulled back the hollow wire
mesh of the stench road which comprises
of a net-like material with 16 sensors
expands out and interfaces with the
walls of the blood vessel the wire at
the other end of the stentrode is then
connected to a very small computer
device that is implanted inside the
patient's chest cavity those signals
travel through
a lead that exits out the body through a
telemetry unit that goes into a computer
and those signals the implant connects
with the rest of the system via
bluetooth either paired with a computer
or even just a smartphone with synchron
stentrode there are no visible signs
that a patient has an implant in their
brain after the procedure another
advantage is that the surgery can be
done in any hospital setting in a few
hours plus this endovascular procedure
is already used for other surgical
treatments and most surgeons are already
trained in this after receiving fda
approval last year syncron has
successfully implanted the stentrode
device on one patient at the mount sinai
hospital in new york they planned to
expand the program to five more patients
as per the fda approval by the end of
this year if their australian trial
results are anything to go by then this
should be smooth sailing for them these
trials were done in 2019 after synchron
received human trial approval from
australian officials for patients with
multiple sclerosis the results saw no
adverse reactions to the implant even
better they achieved unsupervised home
use of the stentrode device in less than
100 days after the surgery at the
trial's end both participants had used
the device for tasks such as text
messaging online shopping and managing
their finances independently looks like
synchron is giving neuralink a run for
their money let's hope that the
competition helps improve both their
products and ultimately the lives of
those who need them so far the only
downside to the synchron stentrode is
that it is inserted inside a blood
vessel that runs through the brain and
not inside the cortex tissue so it does
not physically interface with the
neurons this means that the signal
released is limited and not as strong as
neuralink signal but on the flip side
the implant is much less invasive than
neuralink implications for neuralink it
is still quite commendable that synchron
has made this much headway neuralink may
lag behind but the approval of syncron's
clinical trial represents a major step
towards clearing regulatory and
practical hurdles for the bci industry
in the long run neurolink will benefit
from this as well the trial's success
will also allow neuralink the
opportunity to learn from stentrode
especially regarding data privacy
concerns hopefully by the time they are
ready for human trials neuralink will
have addressed those issues and any
others that are likely to come up along
the way while many of us may never need
medical bcis i am glad that there are
individuals and companies that are
dedicating their lives to developing
this life-changing technology a future
in which disease and injury do not
dictate an individual's independence and
quality of life is one that i cannot
wait to live in how about you what do
you think of these bcis do you believe
neurolink will get approved for human
trials soon let me know in the comment
section below if you enjoyed this video
hit the subscribe button and continue
watching more videos from this channel
by clicking on one of the cards on your
screen see you at the next one